eu ministers for education meeting on
friday
will discuss the development of
entrepreneurial skills through education
and training
they will adopt conclusions highlighting
the importance of promoting
entrepreneurship
from an early age and of reinforcing
links between the education system
and the business world the conclusions
invite member states to fully exploit
the potential
that the erasmus plus program offers in
supporting entrepreneurship education
as well as to make the best use of the
other european resources
such as the european social fund the
contribution of the education sector to
growth and jobs
is also on the agenda a public debate
will be held to analyze the role of
education
in view of the midterm review of the eu
2020 strategy
in the afternoon the discussions will
focus on youth issues
the council will adopt conclusion on
young people's access to rights in order
to foster their autonomy and
participation in society
the effects of the economic crisis have
diminished young people's capacity for
autonomy
ministers will highlight the need to
develop strategies and policies
that guarantee access to services and
education supporting young people's
progress
towards self-sufficiency and citizenship
finally a discussion will be held on how
a cross-sectoral approach to youth
policies
can work as a tool for better tackling
socio-economic challenges
today in the eu 21.6 of young people
between 15 and 24
are unemployed the idea is to discuss
how cooperation between different policy
sectors
can reduce youth unemployment
you